hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to soma now I found out
what I was supposed to do who was in
this little enclosure here where the guy
pulled off his helmet down below and I
don't know if I was supposed to go
wandering around on the grid but I'm
assuming that this is actually important
so before flushing make sure to open
valves and turn on the pump okey-dokey
then
so I'm assuming these are the valves but
they're not moving maybe I'm wrong we
would move it'll move can I do the thing
okay I can do it now rabbit is happy to
have it up okay homina homina homina
alrighty then
is this thing gonna get to go down oh
hey how's it going so hey so it's gonna
empty all Gaius
but I still have the problem of a power
failure I don't know what to do about
that because those tidal generators
outside didn't seem to have a whole lot
of interact ability with it
oh oh okay
why didn't know so someone up here hello
anybody oh hey how's it going
you're dead I might be dead soon okay
probably by emptying out the water a
increase the pressure on the hull of
this little enclosure here and probably
didn't do it a good favor
so hello how are you he touched you
okie dokie then I don't know why I'm but
anything I can't breathe it like the
others I don't even know why you can
read the others anyway it's not like the
others were actually integrated into the
system why are you able to just touchy
them and grab all their memories little
bizarre
maybe I have built-in ability to scan
people's brains okay I don't know what
is
oh hello well then I could have used
that guy but I guess I'll go flying
blind let me just close my eyes and flip
switches maybe I got a get them all this
turning on the generators outside or
something I didn't actually read the
panel before I ripped it off god I'm so
strong I don't need to use my brain for
anything yes I did it I accomplished a
fruitless task there was no reason for
me to do that let me shove my hand in
this thing in celebration
that's the good stuff right there
all right I don't even know if I was
damaged at all
I actually missed out on a few more
conversations outside Oh Catherine we've
got so much to talk about Catherine what
dude where are we
we're right next to Omicron a smaller
building connected to the main site
can't you tell can't you tell
my view is pretty limited there's some
heavy restrictions on my system access
did you find a power suit
not yet trying to figure out how to get
into Omicron the big building okay
keep up the good work thanks Catherine
you got nothing good luck
Simon's thoughts can tackle my own
Catherine what's doing how are you so
okay with all this with what being a
talking box for one thing not being
human it's not so bad so you're not
bothered at all by not having a body I'm
getting there
you're making me feel really
self-conscious look be serious I never
felt that comfortable being human in the
first place
this isn't much worse not being able to
move would freak me out
glad you got the box and not me but make
it a little easier to help out if I had
a body but you're doing good job just
figured being able to stretch a little
would give you some ease my physical
constraints don't translate to my
experience very well I feel about as
human as before but as if suspended in
air which is kind of interesting that I
think about it okay then that's a little
bit of knowledge I mean I'm not entirely
sure what that means or if I'm ever
gonna get you a parent suit why do you
think I was made why would this AI the
Wow bring me here I don't think we could
ever know I'm my own beliefs but nothing
that can be verified tell me why do you
think the wild brought me here the wide
range of assignments but they all sprung
from one single idea
preserve humanity when the comet hit the
earth killing everything leaving a
freshman if humanity left alive
the Wow started to compensate its
restoring humanity I think so but I
don't think we share its definition of
human or life for that matter alrighty
then good to know
got any more insight this is actually
quite interesting alright anyway I'm
pretty sure I need oh are we alive oh
that's an impossible question to answer
we lack meaningful definitions just
figure there must be a way to know you
know if this life is worth living you
assume you've changed so much but have
you really I don't know I don't feel so
different the world sure does I never
realized how much the idea of myself
depended on where I am how do you mean I
miss Toronto not because my friends and
family are there but because I know
where I fit in in Toronto I know who I
am that's an interesting observation
ah okay I see this whole conversation is
here because I was supposed to be doing
a puzzle which leads to the entrance of
Omicron without drawing too much power
which I just did right there pop no
pride at all
I know okay so I got to find a better
route to get to where I need to go which
might be this way
bada-boom I got Omicron open I did I
thought that conversation there was just
for the sake of my own sanity sure we
have any painkillers left this tinnitus
has become quick hurry we only have had
stuff left
morphine level drugs I'm no good my head
is about to explode
can do that stuff for emergencies
besides Cameron thinks the ringing will
settle what Junior reaches a hundred
percent then tell aunt re to [ __ ] off
should be a matter of hours just hang in
there keeping posted yeah well I have
this thing I need to take care of so
I'll talk to you later okay sure thing
lob dis black box humans have black
boxes here we do company policy it
records your vitals to help medical
personnel treat you in case of accidents
that's how I can hear the dead alright
yeah black boxes just like the intercom
of a yeah it has to be a way to cancel
the log down have a look around the room
okay
so there's got to be a code somewhere
around here and I can't read this person
cuz there must have ripped a black box
out or something okay so there's got to
be a co2 way over there you sexy looking
terminal you
get my fingers all over uses what's a
bigger puzzle where do is a balloon
would come from updates enable black
boxes area calibrator diagnostic tool 10
ton temp what you use seven eight is
that important do I need to know about
that okay what is this are you I'm
assuming that secured solve what why do
I get the feeling that we just got
lowered into the back of a van
what are you talking about yay I did it
it seems like something was leading us
here intentions lockdown cancel yay
something wants us to come inside please
want to go inside what's the problem
come on let's get going it seems like
there's a lot of problems here and
Katherine you seem to ear to be
wandering into the Maw's of death to the
maw of death moss is it more or Maw's
talking about a mouth here have it I
have it up okay nevermind then I won't
do that
how about have it have it uh comfort
well dreamed like I'm trapped forever
I'll never be able oh I should probably
do this well I would have been smart but
again I'm not a whole lot of smart
Hey Oh No okay
so why was there the whole portion of
jumping down into the abyss like that
was a path that I could go down why was
it there like it I didn't find any
secret swallows down there so maybe it's
some other motive that I need to do I
have no idea actually it could be
anything
oh hey let's go in there I mean I'm just
a walking suit with a dead body in it
and a program from a bygone era of not
too long ago tomorrow actually okay so
you guys are active but I don't know
where bubble butt is can you tell me
where bubble butt is do you guys know
any of you guys seen bubble but I mean
he's afraid to me right now but he he
you know he loves me I love him maybe
he'd be willing to come back by again
all right oh this looks safe I'm sure
nothing horrible happen while I'm in
here
what about boo be bop boo boo boo oh you
don't get it okay
is this supposed to mean a CR climber
powerlines this is outside the blue dot
on the front door that's where I am
right now
okay then so y ou can I not go in wait
what's going on here hey wait a minute
malfunction use alternate entrance Oh
Hongki this is where I go down okay so I
just went here a step too early that's
what I did huh okay time to go down into
the abyss again and not fall and die
this time although I am proud of myself
for truly for exploring where I didn't
even go away I mean if it's not the
right way that I'm just gonna fall into
the bay
I don't think oh hey that's I don't
think all that happened last time
right cuz I came too early and I didn't
know what I was doing
oh well hello and boink
maybe now there's a secret that's
available but I don't have the patience
to go look for it well that was a little
weird okay
Buddha boo Boop I mean I've been good
about finding the secrets and whatnot
but for the most part I don't feel like
wasting you guys this time by going on a
possibility also I touched up my hair a
bit as you can see it's bubblegum pink I
really like the pink so I can say that I
was gonna keep it a little longer heck
maybe it's gonna be permanent now I have
no idea but it should go from bubblegum
pink to a cotton candy very soon oh
loading loading loading there we go yeah
because ooh hey what the hell happened
here are their heads gone oh hey
lots of loading going on oh that's
that's comforting
I'm glad that music is playing make it
to hear anything in here anything of
Zulu okay enough avoiding here we go
hello what happened to you
yeah I wouldn't think there was a black
box there anyway oh my god did something
blow up their heads yeah these guys are
empty yeah I think I've had my share of
touching dead bodies for now boo boo boo
can I go in there
oh it's using my favorite goo all right
so this isn't the suit I need that's the
scene I'm walking around in this looks
comforting yeah let me see where the
other one leads first then I can make my
choice oh okay
wow this is much more interesting and
much more sinister
global lockdown active override at dive
room console oh there's the slappy
sounds of Robo goop
Robo fluids everywhere okay so this room
is in total lockdown there might be
something that I need the answer to that
question is no okay so now I get to
wander upstairs I know there's monsters
around here I was right I was so right I
was incredibly right who knew how right
I could be anything through the window
peekaboo
I see you I see something whoo hey okay
I wonder if that
and was it the done better hey I need
stop what you need to stop being so
freaky
where the hell was that oh so now we got
ghosts Robo ghosts
that's not fair it's not fair at all oh
you guys are you guys are grouping a
little more than you usually do I hear
something okay so I need to go to the
dive room is what it said do I follow
the trail of blood seems like the
opposite of a good idea but I'm chock
full of bad ideas got to get through
them to get to the good ones hello is
anybody here that wants to stab my eyes
out okay man I wonder if they did
experimentation on the vows original
test subjects ooh
looks like some sort of imaging thing
advanced futuristic MRI I mean all of
its in quarantine so it's got to be
quarantined for a reason something went
bad here some infection went rampant and
I imagine the infection has more to do
with technology than actual biology oh
this seems like a trap I don't like this
all right okay
so far so good of course of course of
course I called this tonight oh I called
this somehow I always knew all right
cancer head oh is this Omaha yes
everything is so basic so limited I hope
it's not the homage to a falling apart
okay we need to find you a power suit
you know so we can go into the abyss
without ending up like a recycle piano
sotto uh-huh we'll find one that fits me
I mean I'm kind of in a suit already
that's been bothering me too
you know how you are transfer from
Vancouver Toronto from then to now how
could I forget okay so we do it again
you want to send me to the future no you
idiot it's for your mind into a new body
what look we already know it can be done
we don't need to make it a big deal it
is a big deal Kath it's a huge [ __ ]
deal there's got to be something else
that can take us down there but done
Bennett data was the only vessel that
could take that pressure and you saw
what happened then think of something
else
Simon please you don't have to switch
this instant just play along for now if
we find something else then great if not
I'm not promising anything
Thank You Simon have a look around the
room this is where they would keep the
Power Suit if there are any left
this is also where they keep the
monsters that want to murder my face I'm
usually the one that does the face
murdering but we got here put them to
neoprene under certain body harness
chick DG is libel dude starting with the
legs fix your pardon the harness tap
secure button on your arm
okey-dokey then ooh ready then seems
more like a suit from Halo than a whoa
they look cool man I wish I was half as
cool as it is that Catherine Catherine's
in a suit I check in a suit that girl
looks mean on the right first it in the
locker Hey
let me deal I'm looking for clues I'm
like scooby-doo in the gang I probably
know what I'm doing
hello our suits testing ready Omicron
scanner in the Ark loaded equipment
climbed climber calibrated for weight
crane operator home Kron standing by for
pickup in two days okay so Catherine was
a part of this crew Catherine was here
at Omicron
I'm guessing finalizing the project for
these that's this that's not comforting
I know there's things in there hi babies
laugh come on how about you shut your
trap oh look there's an arrow pointing
Moo
oh boy along oh god it's got red eyes
glowing at me I prefer blue eyes white
dragons boo boo boo black screen my
favorite okay yeah oh look don't know
door don't turn around on me I found one
of the power suits I was a dead woman
inside at least I think it's a woman
just like the body we found in the annex
she's missing her head gross this could
work in our favor though look for a
terminal nearby see if you can put it up
aah aah
I think she's missing her head I think
that sync'd or it right off oh wow I'm
not okay with this even though that's
probably already with stuffed inside of
me right now
so doesn't mean that I'm okay with this
high-pressure chicken with Dan
temperatures does do a lot of attic
Lucille pressure remain a normal one
Anna veera okay so safest experience
possible yeah don't ask me how she got
stuffed in the suit and then stuffed
into there and also what the hell is
this how about you let me work woman let
me do my thing
yeah all right then
so is there something over here that I
need Oh No
okay so there's gotta be this is a
terminal over there but I need this
terminal activated to do something Oh
obviously can't do anything there so a
terminal over here anything anything at
all I can't go back out so I'm stuck
here uh I don't like this
don't waste time so I didn't have to be
the Power Suit all right I'm trying
please you know it's a little harder
than you think oh I didn't I thought
forgot wait so there's power suits
active but in tau at the climber station
and at Omicron okay pod D ba ba ba ba ba
ba I think it was Dee right not exactly
great a material don't radio just yet
remember what we found out at beta the
suit you are wearing is basically just a
quartet to ship work if you - structure
gel powered by the on suit battery pack
and a dead colleague imaging loop
exactly if you think about it we're
actually incredibly lucky we found a
suit with an already dead body inside
yes you're right
yes it'll play along algorithms set
pattern the Wow won't be able to deny it
even if it was capable of wanting to hey
still not crazy about this plan it feels
wrong please Simon I can't give up on
the arc I need this to work so we need a
cortex chip structure gel and a battery
pack
that's one hell of a shopping list
Thanks I'll just hang around here that's
okay I'll be back
can I leave now now I can leave I guess
I was locked so I wouldn't go anywhere
else all right then I didn't even know I
had a view down there oh this is so much
fun cortex to structure gel and a power
pack to get the stupid I got it geez I
know there's gonna be fun oh well time
to go shopping
hippity hop down to the farmer shop oh
boy
kerosene could burn this place to the
ground like it should be oh god is that
the whales of the Damned then why was
there a ghost telling me that I needed
to stop this is Catherine gonna betray
me is Catherine really not apar good
part of this or Robo Catherine mm well
oh not the whispers I'm not the whispers
oh hello oh look [ __ ] I don't like the
route Burt stop the Wow stop the Wow
we didn't stop the way out I'll run over
load oh this is not good I don't like
this oh I don't like this oh god is it
one of these puzzles what do i doing
what am I doing here
wait what am I trying to do oh I'm
trying to hit all okay I know what it
was okay I got it bang I'm good
okey-dokey then
boo boo boo boo boo boo oh no oh no stop
the WoW get the virus I don't know what
that means
does the WoW need a virus to infect it I
mean this whole game I've kind of been
led to believe that the WoW is like an
unintelligent thing working for the
benefit of just trying to keep people
alive I guess I never did question
Catherine or why she was there oh maybe
I should stop questioning things
so I still gotta find I know all this
bad mothers bad
I'm afraid it's ready yes do you think
how far this we go Oh what makes you
what was your stir crazy right keep it
down there I just thought you could talk
to entity Ronnie
all right so I there's some weird [ __ ]
going on here Wow okay so this looks
like experimentation on the sea
creatures or lease observation of how
the Wow was infecting them oh my God
look at these things all right so so I
may have been able to guess a few plot
points here and there but I'm willing to
bet that there's a deeper mystery here
going on and I'm being misled the one
thing that I can count on is that I am
being used for one reason or another for
better or for worse I'm being used but
that doesn't mean that I'm being used
for bad I could be being used to try to
stop the Wow like my visions are telling
me which could be a good thing or it
could be a bad thing I'm not at liberty
to say just yet
yeah all right so I'm trying to be
observant and see everything but it's
entirely possible that I might miss on
something because I don't know what I'm
looking for
hello Andrew yeah I was talking to
Cameron about protein Salutation do you
think we could break the aggregate
structure gel without flattening the
configuration
Jesus that was a mouthful you've been
listening to Cameron that's for sure
what do you want Raleigh can you blame
me for trying to figure this out I've
been having the dreams too
I don't know what to believe oh I know
everything from the Sun signal
amplification and black boxes to having
a comatose dr. Ross locked up the glass
jar we've all but going a bit nuts tell
me about it just like my head's about to
explode
I'm aesthetically speaking could we stop
that wealth from mutating it doesn't
work like that it was a sight Elfa
hypothetically speaking I guess we could
try rally are you recording this
sorry okay so something's going on like
when they say their heads that's twice
they've mentioned heads exploding and it
seems like out there there seems to be a
lot of exploded heads going on so what
is this site alpha what were they doing
who oh oh oh no oh oh
oh hey no
you mean interest hello Oh your heads
exploded why do these people keep the
black boxes then the cane interface with
you y'all got no heads this guy might oh
no he does not
god damn these guys quite literally had
their brains explode the Wow was like
really really like why would the Wow
keep these guys kill these guys but keep
everything else alive unless the Wow
thought that it needed to kill these
with the freaking thing in the thing
whoo not fun times over there well maybe
the suit
maybe because it's a suit it might have
something probably not though no okay
all right then that's a negative on that
one negative well now in Bigfoot because
that's where it came from
all right so now here's another lockdown
okay override this lockdown upper
goddamn well that was easy
whoa who's dropping [ __ ] I don't like
this
Hey
well what are you are you an animal or
no are you gonna be an enemy oh I don't
want to go ooh
key there's no power packs in there mmm
oh hey hey hey
hi there you've got a claw for a hand oh
what am I supposed to do with you ha
okay okay oh god oh god oh god he's not
moving
oh he doesn't pay attention to noises oh
I don't like him
Oh Oh do I gotta go
oh god oh god okay I didn't do that I
gotta get my thing oh good
I gotta get the thing Oh God huh so I
gotta make a lot of noise bang bang bang
bang bang oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god
okay I'm just gonna get the thing now
I'm gonna get it I'm gonna get it I got
it oh my god hey this oh this is the
worst oh there's the worst I get it I
get it I know it needs to be done I just
need to be whoa I need to be very quiet
cuz he won't she won't she he it won't
notice so long as I'm very careful Hey
Hey
Oh
ah okay done cool great thank you
everybody so much for watching I'll pick
this up in the next episode and as
always a season thanks for you bye bye
good